for the design of a 5 million gallon per
day activated sludge plant to treat
domestic waste water various operational
design parameters have been specified
the parameters are as follows the
ariation Basin will maintain a food to
microorganism ratio of
0.1 one over days the mixed liquor
volatile suspended solids concentration
within the Iration Basin will be 2700 mg
per
liter half of the bod5 or biochemical
oxygen demand over 5 days concentration
will be removed by the primary
clarifier the tank volume is 2,000 cubic
feet determine the influent bod5
concentration in milligrams per liter
before it enters the primary
clarifier so this is a basic activated
sludge treatment problem and all we have
to do to solve it is use our keywords up
here being activated sludge in the
reference manual that's going to take us
to page 455 for the organic loading rate
the organic loading rate is an equation
as
follows
FM equals s
subz q sub
Z over v
x where F to m is the loading rate or
the food to microorganism ratio s notot
is the influent
bod V is the volume of the unit in
million gallons and X is the suspended
solids concentration in parts per
million or milligrams per
liter so we can start writing the these
out because the problem has already
noted what we
have so FM equals
0.1 day to the
minus1 the
mlvss
equals
2700 mg per
liter and then we don't know what bod5
is but we should keep this part in mind
for
later so bod5 is going to be what we're
solving
for and then the tank
volume we've noted is
200,000 cubic
feet and again we're looking for the
bod5 concentration before it gets to the
primary
clarifier so we can start filling this
equation in but before we do that let's
standardize our units
V is specified to be in million
gallons so if we go to our unit
conversions we can see that
7.48
Gall equal 1 cubic
foot so plugging this in multiplying
this is going to give us
1.5 * 10
6 gallons which is the same as
1.5
million
gallons okay now we can fill in the
equation
so FM equal
0.1 day to the
minus1 S notot we said is our influent
bod5 so we're going to have to solve for
that Q is the flow rate in
MGD so that's going to be five
mg
d v we just solved for that's going to
be
1.5
mg and X is the
mlvss as given here and that's going to
be
2700 MGR per liter so we can see that
multiplying this over to here dividing
this and multiplying this is going to
cancel out our million gallons million
gallons our day and our
day so we're going to be left with s
subz or S not
equals
81 millgram per
liter however we need to note that half
the
bod5 was removed before entering the
primary
clarifier so keeping that in
mind the amount com coming into the
entire activated sludge plant is
actually going to be twice that
so
162 millgram per
liter and that's all it takes to solve
this problem it just you have to
recognize that it's an activated sludge
problem know how to find that in the
reference manual so get familiar with
what kind of questions are asked to get
to what kind of equations you're going
to need in the
manual and other than that there are
some basic unit conversions to pay
attention to that they could throw at
you but that's pretty much all it takes
so that's
it